even Liz cross's greatest critics will
praise a political skill that led her
all the way to Downing Street we
shouldn't be daunted by the challenges
we face
as strong as the storm may be I know
that the British people are stronger
catapulted to number 10 with a mandate
from the membership to challenge a
status quo but a mini budget just two
weeks into the job set in motion Liz
truss's downfall
[Music]
and lost another Tory leader the
confidence of the party I think one of
the potentially early missteps on the
political side was to form an
Administration that was so heavily
weighted to those that were on one side
of the leadership contest and not to
have reached out a bit more to the other
side Liz truss was politically engaged
from a young age growing up in Glasgow
and Leeds she described her parents as
left-wing at Oxford University she was
even president of the liberal Democrats
there are two main problems with this
amendment conference
it was in her late 30s that the woman
who would become Prime Minister began to
rise through the Tory ranks she carved
out a position on the right of the party
and became a Grassroots favorite
despite her at times awkward public
appearances
we import two-thirds of our cheese
that is a disgrace
in cabinet she was seen by some as a
troublemaker determined to get her way
some were surprised to see Boris Johnson
promote her to foreign secretary
when the search began to replace him she
made it onto the final ballot for the
leadership by just eight votes mordant
one zero five
sunac one three seven
truss one one three
a path then through the Tory membership
was rarely in doubt
exactly the idea of being stuck in a
lift with care style but strikes being
extremely boring
it was once she got the job things began
to unravel his trusses Premiership
veered off course two days after
becoming the Queen's 15th prime minister
she was confronted by a nation in
mourning
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from Balmoral
when politics eventually did return the
new prime minister was on the back foot
you're prepared to be unpopular aren't
you yes yes I am pushing ahead with a
bold tax cutting agenda blamed for
Market turmoil and political unrest
I'm not going to cut the additional rate
of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
then unceremoniously sacking her
Chancellor and close friend
quasi-quarting is crazy quieting should
list trust resign authority never
recovered
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend
and he shares my vision to set this
country on the path to Grace
the man she hoped could steady the
economy and save her Premiership tried
firstly we will reverse almost all the
tax measures announced in the growth
plan three weeks ago that have not
started parliamentary legislation
but that left Liz truss a prime minister
without a purpose as her home secretary
resigned in chaotic scenes emerge from
The Commons last night it became clear
she couldn't hold on
Liz truss came into office at a time of
global instability but hers was a
Premiership characterized by infighting
and u-turns and shall be remembered as
the shortest serving prime minister in
British history Ali faulsku Sky News
Westminster